[Music]
Jeeter a jaybird we got an email from
aldo jones look at that he wants us to
do a reaction to his venom we're trailer
and I said aldo shudders now we're
already on it buddy
guys did you know venom comes from the
Marvel properties what no yeah so what
speaking speaking of which we want to
give a shout out to today's video
sponsor the good people over at amino
apps we have worked with these guys
before and there's a reason why it's
because their app is killer and our
subscribers that have used the amino
apps are great too loose at this fight
so why not tell you guys about them
again
you may remember us shouting at the
Marvel um you know way back when when we
shot our a man and the wasps trailer
numero dos reaction as well as our
spider-man Home Coming movie review and
we're excited to be working with them
again because like I said the people who
join are very much satisfied so for
those of you who aren't familiar I mean
it was a mobile network of fan and
creator communities that spans pretty
much any conceivable interest you can
think of you could be a Marvel fan what
or a Harry Potter fan yeah for a West
world fan what
Riverdale fan this guy is yeah or a Rick
and Morty fan or any other kind of fan
whatever your interest may be there's a
community of like-minded passionate
people waiting to connect with you an
imino obviously this duo winds up doing
a lot of Marvel related content on this
channel and the Marvel Amino as an
excellent place for fans and creators to
gather together post their reviews and
theories participate in polls share fan
art and a whole lot more you can check
in with you communities in real-time
browse curated feeds and even take
advantage of the app's text voice and
avatar chat features to bring you even
closer with your friends that you make
on the app and if you're familiar with
the fact that youtubers obviously go on
Wikipedia before talking about a Marvel
related video this has a great feature
because the community even has its own
wiki in case you need to brush up on
some of your own MCU knowledge and if
you're a fan of our videos it's a great
place to keep track of our Marvel
related content which we've been posting
over there with each new Marvel related
video in short guys with Amino it's
easier than ever to
but with the people all over the world
who share your love your passion for
your favorite fandoms and to contribute
to the conversation of the fandom
community so guys who find a link in the
description box to download the app and
don't forget to follow us at real
rejects all one word and be sure to
check out our various videos and pulls
in stuff we've made a lot of posters
over there by now so check out some of
those let us know your thoughts and huge
thanks again to the folks over at amino
app we have had a great time partnering
with you guys we love the app and we
love that people actually use the app or
loving it too this makes us happy hard
to find good partners like you guys
anyway let's hop into this weird trailer
Doug Jones Jones
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
guy who is the evil person what about
the allegation what if you recruit the
most vulnerable for tests that endeavor
stability
[Music]
[Music]
pretty good at it you are
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you will only hurt bad people now you
want to kill the spider you want to kill
the spider
you don't stand a chance
interested
[Music]
[Music]
what the hell are you
[Applause]
what you're fired
it's so caught up in that I forgot to
even look for her cap shield or anything
Aldo you bet your sweet buttocks we are
liking this video buddy oh yes in fact
guys you must become a patron Aldo Jones
if you haven't pledged to Aldo Jones's
page what are you doing I mean we
haven't yet but what are you doing why
haven't you pledged you know what we
should pledge to Aldo Jones's page right
right now see I'm clicking buttons let
me help with with the computer whoa
we've just pledged ah a huge amount I'm
sorry I'm allergic to 10% of whatever
this video earns we'll go right into our
pockets as well as the other 90% that's
how much we support you Aldo you know I
love about this video John what do you
love about this video job you know how
he loves to use the toes McGuire's
videos I do this from the spider-man 3
specifically it fits perfectly for guys
love that you might get to a point where
I get it aldo I'm sick of seeing Tobey
Maguire from spider-man 3 in your weird
trailers but for venom makes more sense
than ever a feature in there it gave it
like a weird shade of narrative where it
seems like Tom Hardy's Eddie Brock is
just being haunted by the spirit of
James Peters a little bit of Topher
Grace Wow just the venoms and symbiotes
who've come before what I liked about
this one too is it's still the same
wacky weird Aldo
he kind of toned it down a little bit
which this mate seemed a little more
focus yeah it seemed a little bit more
specific I don't know Aldo at all all I
know is I get emails from him whenever
he has a new video although could not
even be a real person
Aldo could just be like a computer's
even that real video we saw of him one
time that could be fake could just be a
rendering I feel he composes his edits
around whatever the tone of the trailer
really is as strange as that might sound
because he's obviously making some
really wacky decisions yeah these are
abroad these kind of felt more like
letting the scenes really play out like
with the res Ahmed with the finger yeah
no threat or taking Drax in the store
yeah or like ways choking someone and
it's the Bart Simpson joke yeah that's
clever this one I thought was actually
more clever because it seemed a lot more
or less random weird zany which I of
course loved an exception this guy yeah
there's there's something about it here
where it felt a lot more what would what
come you find more naturally yeah
there's sort of like a rhyming slang
structure to where the references come
from kinda and that's a nice thing to
have a little bit more design in this
one yeah just making like little scenes
and making little recurring characters
out of these was a nice touch there's a
nice mix up from what you normally
expect from Alda who just makes like
super zany hyper fast-paced stuff yeah
that was a nice balance we have bits and
then bits that kind of followed a theme
I like to how this time you played so
much with like taking a reverse shot or
something and then like lengthening it
out so they just become these like long
awkward pauses right we're like looking
at each other and kind of [ __ ] and they
start singing like Indiana Jones and
then like harmonizing was yeah he made
like actual scenes out of it I thought
that one of the best splicing effects he
did was the et yeah then when you could
see in the mind of Aldo is my would have
gone to this as being the next decision
because sometimes he still has a lot of
the wow that's just wacky and Aldo was
clearly on some pills that night other
times it does seem like a really natural
transition of her I could see why he
thought that would be the next thing to
put there you know the floating bike
shot I understand yeah is that Aaron
taylor-johnson pooping I thought that
was who that was but I'm not sure I
haven't seen the movie I don't know what
that's from all I know is I got to see
that movie yeah I want to see him poop
that's my favorite thing to do is watch
celebrities poop some people like nude
pics some people like celebrity tirades
I like celebrity poops if I could watch
more celebrities pooping that would be a
compilation right there alright guys
well you can subscribe to the reject
nation subscribe buttons make Ark
look flashy and they do not represent
the average video of you count you could
click our notification bell it won't
really do much else but supposedly it
does check out aldo jones on patreon
don't check us out seriously aldo jones
is the one you gotta check out for
patreon as a matter of fact i'm gonna
link his patreon page right here boom
boom